[Music]
the million abilities unification man
now set blue la méditerranée man janab
Allah SWA ultimate want if I'm back I
want you to just silently do
Manon say John Kennedy Levin de la côte
d'ivoire the mopey la población
soothe
yeah pidemo je n'ai pas de travail
wallop aqua jet Monday me para Wawa envy
new simple 1kp sathi
[Music]
los convene an Italian salami la
méditerranée la May at a time and Angela
measure V buku buku buku the person to
Jean Marie de vermois not settle ooh
Barbarossa Panaji
J Tremblay bascarsija nice a Papa can't
a concern wah down low come on to
peaceful called a persona VMV Unisa
Peppa
Massena Nishita que da same prey vive
colmar a noisy amo una cita di maría me
llamo Josep a pinche sono you dive
master
[Music]
IRRI got SEMA grantee doll Africa or
even aqua cantante difficult I Quinn
DeVivo no el Mar a commune Emeco Triana
fala preceded a lista to toe not ego
NCMA I profess sorry me on Oprah posto
for Mari ragazza Kelly O'Donnell intern
della scuola Jason O'Day my grantee
common Matar a coma verona Tomita
sub-aqua
[Music]
okay what the a service fira a primo
step again oh yeah [ __ ] a dream of course
so probably over capo a stray too far
she'll ever Lauro power front are
equally case oh no they problema que
potrebbero very when end of radii
maintain aqua true see sister you
accompany Pompey doesn't print copy
lapis lapis on LSP la prima voltage a no
Liberty Amina qua non sap llamo qual a
cerrar la Lori a Sione you call cosas
que no es a PMO difficile a ver que
cuando Lauro in Trenton aqua demo no
Vinci la ropa
[Music]
amongst na valo como un ash voila Puma
and embody lo que kendama me info komen
police of a common pillow pranayama me
professor ta news on Sinisa coma la
person to keep a person in DMV una volta
super auto quest a Kevin Devine equally
a postmaster de la loire o difficult
apoyan aqua una lettera need in
traditional ah subahu s pagando perky
door opening / ra Amari Avery Elle mary
quinn depart endo prima di tutto da
respeto Delmar
[Music]
an affair is only experienced this a
dodgy blurry say to you lava
[Music]
la cosa pupil ah de la soupe aqueon on a
tanto vada Reesa Reesa my ver a la luz
en el Yahud universal
non è una Nostra Victoria my una Laura
Victoria
[Music]
Alfonzo pepper if you do
graça duty samba de l'ombre moment flip
is 40mm is an array yami-san chez moi ma
vie my future deficit rabbi poker on
kikusui V V D Raja basically gonna
prepare on call that me
[Music]
[Music]
especially comes to prayer and reveal a
division they are vizier kappa model
ishigami becoming our hood account the
devastation hub then we shipped a very
apparent a lot of possible of nd no no
me Manuel who receive ye marathi telugu
monisha Petacchi paramedic is a former
quizzical mister Shabalin far too much
of each page so that people toward i
else naked osaka hindi movie busca la
guerra lanois pyaar hai usko leg twisted
separate our proceed a prophecy hopeful
who met Robin a protectorate and a
Devdas - yo yo yo boo netows metope puto
yo J travel on a future occasion every
final ceviche porque availa civil Senate
report rigid procedure tells no idea
Yair focused on tasajo trial rapido
circuit la tombe professor hope it is
romantic table for you ski gear soft we
have a technical chief Tata sauce the
Pella primera vez conferring huzzah
hopefully in notable nada - ba also to
the people taht Patras postal mail
dailies
is far as fast as such as partisan from
erotically Dodge okay okay no develop a
sense enjoyment I see pleaded the
trouble Calcavecchia
[Music]
Carmen water today
Elia in the only market justice
especially ideally at a pocket them to
travel you can be frozen
can you at all okay why positive in
order to a personal thing so I ever
killed retouch it achieve a test on the
fastest I hope video say he'll grant
young live with universal producer
buddhaya North Omaha I'm looking over
[Music]
watch a letter from Canada China control
the Andrea Neutron will show me another
tomorrow children whether Pavarotti over
the coronary 20 cartoons on John
Mearsheimer shop there are copied over
too much Suzanne Jana tells you to draw
directly on Susanna fatal of World War
when will your children should say how
they hold a play yeah well what kind of
a challenge here just a woman to undergo
the internal hernia come to life which
is the rotors are come to serve mine
with a one time my mother triggered
watched my mother take a hamsa we're
told it is who are you to know whether
the quantity is a way to how that
tomoyo-chan a woman the body cuz you
know you go to her the Nora
Yasuda I want segurança manizer children
come on idea there's a woman that you
know John kind of Commissioner fish
[Music]
- what is your terminal manager
even though cover so much
Jochen - yeah
first you take ma mère église that the
baby they took a movement all the other
the entity type womanly under the he
broke down brother saw so the woman come
with you make a deal of emerges hanjiro
oh my daughter you got the target
[Music]
[Music]
it's something that you feel a
connection to people automatically I
don't think there's a better feeling you
can kind of move the night with the
music and the energy of the people can
also move me it just really builds
fulfilling
[Music]
hi I'm angel
I'm trend where it's windy J's and
producers what makes a good DJ's being
observant if I play one track and I'm
just like everybody really responded to
that it's knowing in your head in a
split second I've got 10 of the tracks
of sound just like that we do switch off
usually every 30 minutes she can kind of
like move off of what I did when we're
not playing we're watching the audience
she'll be playing and I'll come over and
we're up with like planet mix I know
when my twin has it we'll be okay
we open the bar up in the bronx new york
and it's a religion making area a lot of
reggae playing out in the streets all
the time in fifth grade we entered this
program that helps inner-city youth that
are generally under privileged we got
very lucky but some kids don't get as
lucky we got through middle school in
high school and we got into Dartmouth
and both decided to go so when we
graduated we came back to the city I was
playing with equipment on and off I went
home one day and I told her like this is
what we have to do after you graduate
from college nobody's thinking you'll
then go on to become a DJ it was one of
those moments we had to be resolute and
what you were doing there's a kick yet
and then the base hits I kind of liked
it
I think DJ is definitely a predominantly
male industry we've heard some
negativity from not even other DJ's but
people and audiences and I think it's
been surprising just because it doesn't
feel like DJing should be a gendered
thing I take a burden upon myself to
perform better because we are women we
do get a lot of good feedback from girls
and women who want to learn it do you
want to learn how to DJ if someone told
me that I would end up being a
professional DJ with angel I would not
have believed it
when you follow what you like then you
follow your dreams it can take you
anywhere
[Music]
you